myself heads who of you likes free food
perfect because free pizza changed my
life it was a cold October evening my
freshman year at college and I was in
the main building of my university the
Warsaw School of Economics finishing up
the last day of a five day marathon
called Student Union elections campaign
now I had dedicated all my time to this
ever since high school I wanted to
become a policymaker and work in
Brussels in the European Union
structures so I was dedicated and
becoming a member of my University
Student Union seemed like a natural next
step to achieving my professional goal
nothing else mattered so let October
evening is I was packing up my things I
bumped into my friend coincidentally
named me Hall as well he said I'm hungry
let's grab a slice of pizza that they
have in the room upstairs in one of the
student clubs meetings he said it would
take only a minute now I was exhausted I
was exhausted to the point that I think
actually snoozed when he was telling me
this but somehow I agreed
unfortunately that minute turned into a
dreadful hour a dreadful presentation
that I had to sit through the
presentation was called consulting the
best job in the world I was really angry
at him and as soon as they finished I
just stormed out of the room I went back
home as I got back home I opened my
laptop and there was an email from him
saying well you left before they started
signing people up for projects so I
signed you up for one now I was not
happy or thankful but I am happy today I
am happy that I bumped into him I am
happy that I had this hour-long slice of
pizza and I am thankful that he signed
me up for this project because of this
project I actually joined the consulting
Club and the next year I became its
president in this club I first heard the
name Procter & Gamble and I fell in love
with marketing which led to my career in
brand management and eventually got me
here
so the slice of pizza that I had no
rational reason to go for at the moment
actually inflicted series of events that
changed my life choices now ever since
then I've had many more serendipitous
events in my life and each single one of
them led to the happiest memories and
the closest relationships that I cherish
and hole deep in my heart now to me this
is the true impact of serendipity why am
I telling you this
because I know that each single one of
you has had at least one serendipitous
event in your life even though you might
not know what you did to make this
opportunity happen so today I want to
share with you four suggestions that
helped me increase their independence
and hopefully will help you as well so
number one just turn up when I was
working in Procter & Gamble in Geneva
there was a small digital media agency
they reach out to me and ask me if I can
have an hour meeting with them I didn't
want to for three reasons I wasn't
looking for a digital agency I was
swamped with work and it was the last
week before the three-week vacation that
I had booked a year later a year earlier
but again somehow I agreed we had to
call exchanged emails did not talk for a
year after a year I got shipped back to
Poland and I was in need of a digital
agency so I called them up I hired them
we did the project it was super
successful so I went out for beers with
one of the co-founders after two or
three beers I think I became a little
bit too sincere with him because because
I told him that I'm actually really not
happy with my current position at P&G
and I want to change something in my
professional life I wasn't looking for
advice but what he said next just hit me
like a rock he said why don't you get an
MBA you know what he was one of only
five GSB grads that lived in Poland at
that time were the chances right now he
helped me with the application wrote one
of the recommendation letters and the
rest is history so we have to often find
ourselves being invited to meetings
at least my default is to decline when I
don't see an immediate benefit but I
challenge you just as I challenge myself
to make just turn up a rule number to
put yourself in the right place so this
happened when I was junior at my college
and I wanted to spend my summer in
marketing at a CPG company the best in
the world not Pepsi PNG I'm sorry sorry
Procter & Gamble now the tough part is
that they had a limited number of slots
and it was really hard to get hold of
marketing managers so what I did is I
applied to an IT case study of course
with no prior IT background somehow I
got in now when I walked into the room
and everyone started introducing
themselves
I really felt out of place because there
are 29 CS and engineering majors and me
marketing and management major but you
know what one of the panelists was a
brand manager and I was the only person
interested in marketing so I just
approached him after the case study I
told him hey can we grab a coffee
this coffee led to me getting an
interview and eventually getting an
internship so per freezing famous Steve
Ballmer's presentation to developers
location location location
if you want to find relevant people to
your cause make sure you put yourself
right in the middle number three you
certainly pretty engines I started my
blog in July 2013 just before coming to
the GSB and throughout the last one and
a half years I've had more people reach
out to me than throughout the previous
28 years of my life in fact one person
wrote to me that my blog was one of the
reasons that he applied to the GSB he
got in and he's coming next fall so who
knows maybe he'll become my future
co-founder and fellow billionaire but my
point is here that there's so many of
those engines and you can name them
WordPress medium Twitter Facebook and I
think it's a sin not to be using them
because they're out there 24/7 so they
create this amazing background hum for
for opportunity and and for serendipity
and last but not least is don't require
a reason particularly in business school
I find myself needing a reason for every
single thing I do in fact last year I
signed up for a disco class called
leadership through flow people asked me
is like why did you do that and I told
them like I don't know and to be honest
with you I still have no clue why I did
that but it was refreshing it was fun
and I learned that such seemingly
insignificant thing as posture can have
a major impact on how people perceive
your leadership skills so it's okay to
say I don't know why it's okay to do
things even if you don't know why
because the experience and the knowledge
that you can get out of them can benefit
you in the most unexpected of
circumstances now there's an obvious
danger there's an obvious danger with
serendipity there's an obvious danger in
chasing those open-ended opportunities
that might not have have an immediate
benefit in your life the danger is that
you get distracted from your day-to-day
work and you become frustrated but you
know what if you don't open your life
for serendipity you'll get stuck in a
rot
and you'll become miserable so what I
think the solution is is to find the
Goldilocks zone of not too little not
too much just enough so that the next
time your friend tells you there is a
free pizza at an event take him or her
on it because that free pizza can change
your life it surely changed mine thank
you